the try guys have tried a lot of medical
stuff
let's see what's been legit and what's
been not
the try guys the try guys guys
try prostate exams the try guys guys try
prostrating ah movember is this thing
that helps raise money and awareness for
prostate cancer movember's a great
organization we're not growing mustaches
we're doing one better and it involves
the finger butt stuff today we are going
to get our prostates examined at least
they said finger i remember watching the
first episode of grey's anatomy i'm just
gonna insert my fingers
into your rectum why fingers i if it
takes just one finger up the butt to
find out a life or death situation stick
the whole hand up my butt wait what do
you say prostate cancer is the most
commonly diagnosed cancer
amongst men in the united states very
important to point out while it's the
most common cancer it's also the cancer
that'll many men die
with
not of so like there's a huge majority
of men over the age of 80 who actually
have prostate cancer but end up dying of
other causes so what we've come to
realize and how we've changed our
management with prostate cancer is
unless it's an aggressive form of
prostate cancer or a treatable form of
prostate cancer we do a watchful waiting
period where we monitor but don't
actually treat because what we've come
to realize is treatment and even
diagnosis in some cases can be worse
than just letting the disease be it
rarely occurs in men under 50. oh i
don't actively think about being
susceptible to cancer it's not in my
family i'm a young person who can take
on the world testicular cancer is a
cancer that the try guys need to worry
about okay that was a weird scene and i
don't know if they did that for comedy a
doctor should never be palpating an area
without visualizing it yes you might be
able to feel masses but you might miss
like a terrible rash you might press on
an area that's very tender because
testicular cancer is the most common
cancer amongst men aged 20 to 40. that's
true and actually testicular cancer has
this like weird bimodal distribution
where it peaks in younger men kind of
flattens out and then also peaks in
older men as well the good part about it
is it's rare the second good part about
it is quite treatable even if it spreads
so we're going to do the genes urinary
exam and examine your testicles to see
if there's any abnormality okay we're
not just checking the testicles we're
checking the epididymis we're checking
the glands we're checking for rashes
we're checking the pubis we're checking
the pubic hair the left one feels just
fine do we need a cough you don't need
to cough when people say to cough what
we're actually looking at is hernias
which are checked in the same area and
the reason we cough by the way is to
raise intra-abdominal pressure so when
we are in the inguinal canal if there is
a hernia we'll feel it poke and hit like
the intestines or abdominal contents
poke our finger while we're in there men
that are aged 25 to 40 have to get their
nuts felt and men that are age 50 or
older have to get their butts poked
that's basically right that's not
basically right we actually have moved
away the united states preventive
service task force states that prostate
exams are a shared decision-making
process between a doctor and a patient
not something that is unequivocally
recommended eye on your side with your
right side down bring your knees up a
bit
to expose your bottom okay
bottom exposed don't some people bend
over yeah that can be done also you can
just stand up and lean over and put your
elbows on the tape has anyone done like
missionary style the doctor had us lay
on our sides eugene of course bent over
because he's eugene i think it goes
deeper when you do doggy style and he
poured a ton of lube on that finger
actually when we were med students we
would do this and i remember the
simulated patient that would actually be
having it done to him multiple times
over and over again would check our
nails and had a nail clipper with him to
actually decide should someone clip
their nails before doing it because
apparently people have heard him in the
past pressed his finger up against my
delightful anus oh
pressure and then just went black
she was in my butt oh my god oh my god
and then he said okay we're going and
then
and it's nice and smooth great
you're essentially checking for masses
you're doing like a sweeping motion
because the prostate is at the bottom
portion if you feel any irregularities
if you feel enlargements those are all
potential abnormalities everything feels
fine normal smooth so that was efficient
super quick
very painless whoa that was way deeper
than i expected lubed up in and out and
you feel fine all right okay and here's
some tissue if you need it
i actually did a simulated prostate exam
on a robot in the uk on live television
here you go so we have to do something
called the digital rectal exam it's a
finger up the bum isn't it it's a finger
up the bump
what are we going to be doing today well
today we're going to be doing a little
bit of electric stim on our gentleman
right here we're going to use it to
simulate and mimic labor pains do you
think we'll die once we can't handle any
more pain our safe word is epidural
childbirth is so painful that you would
gladly have a needle stuck between the
two vertebrae in your back it is a
needle and then usually a catheter is
inserted over it in order to give a
continuous line of medication and the
purpose is not for anesthesia but for
analgesia to basically allow the patient
to not feel terrible pain but to still
keep some sensation of their
contractions keep some ability to
contract and push this will mimic a lot
because it'll actually make the whole
abdominal region contract in real
childbirth it's your full torso it's
your stomach and it's your back and your
uterus so you can put it inside you you
may not know this but a great many woman
poop on the delivery table because the
act of pushing is very much like having
a bowel movement that's very true and
that happens quite often i think i've
said it like so many times in my videos
and people still don't believe me
i
am a girl i'm a
epidural ironically i feel like i've
seen that happen in the hospital where
patients said that they didn't want an
epidural and then they changed their
minds my wife had an emergency c-section
with our first child so i'm behind
occurred with my wife and the doctors
are doing their thing behind the curtain
they said wait until we give you the cue
to stand up
i thought i heard the cue
so i stood up and i'm gonna predict what
he's gonna say he's gonna say that the
uterus is completely inverted and laying
just on the belly and he passes out and
i looked and what i saw was my wife's
abdomen you know cut open and clamped
back and on a table next to her they'd
taken out her intestines and her
whatever and all this stuff they were in
bowls
they did not remove his wife's liver i
promised he did not remove his wife
maybe it was the placenta or something
but
this is travis this is one of ned's best
friends they went to high school
together so this is our high fidelity
birth simulator her name's fidelity high
fidelity
so it's time let's do this all right
honey i need you to push for me and as
we're pushing nine
eight all right so this is going to be a
lot of pain and pressure for the mother
you're doing great maybe you're doing
great travis oh my god exactly
[Music]
oh you're doing so good a lot of times
it's nurses doing the coaching a lot
better than the doctor's not gonna lie
what do you mean help him all right so
what do i do
help spreads olivia so basically what
you want to do is you want to control
the baby's head so it comes out very
slowly and gradually because the last
thing you want is for it to come out
real quick and then actually cause a
tear in the vagina so you want to
control it and make sure it's coming out
smoothly and help the baby rotate out so
that there is no chance of shoulder
essentially getting caught and causing
damage to the nerves uh that supply the
arm
oh god it's insane maybe his head's
coming out
there we go at that point you want to
visualize that the umbilical cord is not
wrapping around the baby's neck because
otherwise you want to remove it right
away because it could actually choke the
baby she's like screaming now right like
how do i kind of just like defuse the
situation like emotional get the baby
out
why are you tipping it away from the
table i don't want the table to catch in
real life you have to catch the baby i
have to catch a baby well it doesn't
shoot out the last part does shoot out
because remember there's a lot of force
and then once like the major areas like
the shoulders and the hips are out then
the baby's kind of very slippery so you
want to be able to get a good grasp
grabbing um almost like by the back of
the neck gives you a better support on
the top and then the second hand is on
the bottom gently push down and then
gently pull up so down so when you push
down you actually drop the shoulder
below and then you get the other
shoulder up as well maybe so oh there we
go
yeah no that was a little too hard sorry
right as far as baby is out there you go
look at that
you cut it see look don't catch it there
you go perfect
and right away we do something called
baby to breast where we bring the baby
once we make sure that the baby's apgar
scores are okay we bring the baby to the
mom put on mom's chest a lot of moms
spend some time with it bond right away
we see better outcomes like that less
stress for the baby as well
also during the process you always want
to keep an eye on the dad that the dad
just
or the partner is just like
boom
the try guys aren't the only ones who
try i tried out some of the most crazy
and some good kickstarter products click
here to check that out as always stay
happy and healthy there's one that made
me gag click here to check come on watch
it